[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
so it's today I wanted to share with you
the unlock the power a feature based
JavaScript development my email is Jeff
at code winds my handle there is Jeff be
ski on Twitter and github and then the
slides will be available or they are
available at code winds calm /j s kampf
2018 so you can get all the slides and
notes so have you ever entered into some
code base and then looking around in it
and you're like what is all this doing
and why is it here and you look at some
of the comments and it doesn't help and
you know eventually you get you get
looking through and you just like this
is just like you know some complicated
mousetrap or something you know it
doesn't make any sense why all this
stuff's here and then you do a get blame
on it to find out who did it and you
realize you know it was you you know
anybody anything happen to anybody
before I think Michael Chan said that
you know code that you've written six
months ago is uh is often code you don't
like anymore so you know it's it doesn't
have a you know you always learn more
things and new things and well that's
happened to me before
Who am I married I've got a one grown
daughter active in our Catholic parish
and been active in JavaScript wrote of
past seven years I got some open source
projects oh it's cutting off on me into
Dario see there you go so I started a
small company code winds so I do
training and consulting so if you need
any help on any of these things I'd love
to help you with your project
so why feature-based development what
what are we talking about well software
is is is complex and you know there's
always more things to keep getting added
to it and so it's you know it's
something that's always getting more
complicated
you know we've learned to start out and
do like MVPs you know so we can try to
get something out to the customer so
they can see it quicker and those things
have kind of you know evolve how we do
software you used to try to plan out
every possible thing up front and you
know you never even get started you know
the project takes years to be for you
all the planning so now we're at least
delivering you know value sooner and so
with Sprint's and trying to evolve the
code so we've tried to do this feature
base stuff before you a lot of times we
use git commits you know and branches to
try and put whole features together and
move them in a merge at a time and we
and the other thing we try to do is
organize by feature so a lot of times
you'll see people trying to organize
their code base so that all the things
around a particular domain or portion of
the screen are all handled in one area a
lot of times you've with feet you know
features you want to do a/b testing so
you'll want to turn on a new feature or
you want to change a feature to a new
new version so sometimes you might have
feature switches where you want people
to be able to do that early adopters
might you know be able to try some of
your new code app so what are the
challenges with with feature base 2
element well sometimes maintaining
flexibility so we start to get too rigid
and we can't use new technology we can't
it would get locked into certain
frameworks so that can be a problem
wiring and boilerplate sometimes it's
just a mess to try and code this stuff
up so it even you know hooks together so
it's a lot of work sharing across
features can be challenging as far as
trying to keep things isolated but yet
still be able to share things and then
also to be able to fire things off at
the right time so sometimes things need
to happen in order and different things
like that so hooks and dependencies are
challenges so some previous things that
you could have done to try and do
feature based development or you could
have like I said mention are used pull
requests and do emerge things together
but you know sometimes you you get
through the development of the branch in
the feature and then it gets held up you
know maybe it's waiting for something
else to be done
or people want to review it again or you
know those guys are busy on something
else and so sometimes things don't line
up and then you know things get merged
out of order and it's just it's a mess
you know it can be really challenging to
try and move the code together it's hard
to it's hard to a/b test to if you if
these features are developed you know
where they be replace each other you
know with the commits then there's no
way to go back or you know in all that
so it's it could be tricky
so there's some boilerplate projects
that try to you know kind of take this
idea of adding features at a time until
they leave include like a CLI where you
can you know generate some code that's
already hooked up you know so that helps
it can work but you know you're kind of
locked into whatever they have you know
what if you know hopefully it's an
active community and they're still
developing it and you know upgrading it
but you kind of are stuck you know if
they're using the specific technology or
you're kind of locked into that so it
can be pretty you know and so it can
over time it can get stale especially if
they move on to other things so the
dependency injection frameworks you know
there's probably a thousand different
ones out in MPM a lot of them are kind
of complicated and they do all kinds of
different things but from what I've seen
I haven't really seen any that really
fit this feature-based development
process very well you could just take a
global object and start throwing stuff
on that but you know there's you can
obviously have collisions name
collisions and things so that you don't
know you know there's no protection
against overwriting something else and
no use it's contracts and stuff like
that so there's there challenges with
doing that kind of a template so that
leads me to feature you so this is a
library that Kevin Bridges wrote one of
my good friends I worked with Kevin for
about eight years of our GA in st. Louis
and Kevin's just he's an inspiring guy
to me he's he's had the long career you
know and and I know I've went through my
career ups and downs and got burned out
a few times and fired back up and Kevin
just seems like he's just one little
solid guys that just you know plows on
through creates beautiful software great
documentation and so he was working on a
react native an expo project
and he got the idea well if he could try
and extract this feature you based
approach from his existing project he
started to see some similarities and how
things might be able to pull doubt be
pulled out from his app and so that's
how future you kind of came about he
started from that idea so this is you
know primarily for a reactor a react
native or Expo type app but I think the
ideas are good and I think you know it
could easily be applied to a lot of
different frameworks and that so it's
really more Universal Nass so the
project is at feature UJS org and his
github is there with Kevin ast so what
are the benefits of feature you
well it's designed for feature
development I mean he it's that's what
he built it for it's simple and flexible
it doesn't have a lot of those
complicated things that the DI
frameworks have it makes it easy for
cross feature sharing it makes it easy
to capsulate things into into specific
features organizing by feature testing a
and B test a and B testing and it's
dramatically it reduces your boilerplate
and wiring out when I saw how little
wiring you have to do once you start
using this I was like wow this is this
is good I mean this is good just even
from you know non-feature development if
you wanted to get get up and going you
know it just really dramatically reduces
that wiring
he's also got lifecycle hooks where
things will fire off at the right time
so you can build that into your features
he has this the concept of aspects where
you can extend with new technology so
this can just be added in and all of a
sudden now you have a new technology
that's that's being used and he's got
really good validation across all this
and usage contracts so one of these
things that's kind of difficult with
with defining stuff across dependencies
an app is to make sure you've got all
the things accounted for so if you're
expecting a widget over here to come
through you got your you want a widget
come to come through over here you want
to make sure it's it's matching up you
spell everything right you know it's all
hooked up and you want to know quickly
if it's if it hasn't so a high-level
overview how this works we create and
register features so
that's the kind of the main main part of
it you can instantiate and register
certain aspects if you need them so
things like Redux or Redux logic or he's
got a built-in feature router that works
well with with react native then you
launch the app with the features and
assets it actually has a hook where you
just define what it's going to do when
it launches and it takes care of it it
does all the heavy work of wiring things
up and Verret validating and then
features themselves can define what he
calls facets or feature asset and that's
there for cross cross feature sharing so
that's I'll show you a little bit more
about that and features will basically
define them and other features will use
them so then that way that's how you get
the cross sharing and feature you can it
can help manage and validate those paths
so like I said it if you define the
contracts it'll actually make sure that
they exist and are spelled right and all
that so I don't don't know if you can
read this chart very well but you can
look at the slides later and it kind of
just summarizes what I was talking about
we got a bunch of different features
that make up your app launch app brings
it all together it exposes it pulls all
the facets that are defined across all
the features pulls it together into an
object and gives it to your to your app
so here's a just example of kind of the
structure you might use and you could
really use whatever structure you want
but this seemed to work pretty well with
feature based development and so you
basically would have you know an index
file that kicks everything off calls the
launch app pulls together the features
and all that and then I like to have
like a features directory and in each
directory in the index that accumulates
all of them and then in different
directories for each feature so then and
that might just be an index file or it
could be an index and actions file and a
producer file and you know you could
split it up however you want components
you know everything everything that's
related to that feature can all live
together right there and at one one spot
so this feature object is a kind of a
key concept so you basically call create
feature you give it a unique name and
this will and if you name it the same
thing it'll complain got validation and
make sure you know each features got a
unique name
he's got an optional flag for if it's
enabled or not so you can actually
toggle this on and off with logic you
know if you wanted and then the facets
part that's where you actually would
define and use facets so you can
actually define what you assets that you
provide from your feature and ask that
you want to use in this case then it
would validate that those those assets
those facets live or exist somewhere
that they're created and then in this
case if we're using redux then there
might be a reducer that's associated
with it and if using Redux logic then
you might have a logic array if it comes
with it and then some optional callbacks
app will start and an app did start and
it provides you hook then where you can
provide what what the you know the app
was gonna start up with with the
component and also you know fire off
other things later so it gives you those
nice hooks and I mentioned in the
feature directory I had like an index
file and in there I basically import all
the features that I'm that I have and
then export them as a array and so this
will be the actually the arrays the
array of features that gets used by our
launch app and so here's launch app and
this was in the source index file so we
might have a couple aspects that I've
created here I've used in Redux Redux
logic if you don't have any then those
will be you know just the empty array I
got my features coming in from source in
our source feature index and then
basically called register root app and
kind of whatever code I need to do so
for web app react app then you would
call react Dom render for an expo app
you call expo dot register root element
and you know whatever whatever at you
need to do for your startup so this
would work with many you know many
different types of systems so features
aspects register facets kind of context
so this cross feature sharing usage
contracts so this is a kind of this kind
of evolved from the first version that
Kevin created he created the first
version back in March and like I said he
specifically was using an expo at the
time and then when I
I started to look at it to help him I
was gonna put a web app with it through
it through it then we realized there
needed to be some some changes to make
it a little simpler and live different
interfaces for UI sharing and cross
cross future sharing so basically we
kind of evolved it and then went through
you some design sessions and then Kevin
went back and and implemented version
one so this is what this usage contracts
look like for for cross feature sharing
so basically in this case and the facets
I've got a I'm saying that I'm going to
use these types of assets and I'm
basically I'm looking for a bar link
component and a cat route component and
a dog action dot D and I can actually
you know say whether it's by default
it'll be required I can say it's not
required so it won't fail if it's
missing so maybe it's something that
you're checking for and you know later
on that might feature might become
available and then you know you can have
a validation function he's got some
existing ones you can use and then you
can also supports wild cards so this is
kind of a neat concept because you could
say I'm gonna I'm gonna say throw out my
different features I'm going to specify
components that are going to show up on
the main menu of the app you know and so
so you can different features can all
you know or a different part that's
gonna show up on the on the different
route or whatever so for your app so
that way you can you can have loud cards
so then things can be added on the fly
and you know they'll show up the defined
part is where your feature is actually
providing the the facet and so you're
basically just saying here's a facet
here's the name and here's what you know
and I'm defining what it what it is so
I'm passing like here I'm actions food
actions and then if you use the the
third one that define use it basically
is saying I'm defining it but I also
expect it to be used somewhere so if
it's not then then go ahead and throw an
error because I know this should match
something that's already out there and
so I'm gonna use that so it's kind of a
third third thing is saying its defined
and used and so this is kind of nice if
you like I said if you know it should
match that'll just help catch you know
spelling spelling errors and stuff like
that so that'll make sure that it gets
used
cross features so this is a diagram that
shows kind of that in basically says he
features or defining at facets they're
using facets and then launch app is
basically making sure all these things
exist validating things putting all to
bring them all together and he does all
the work for you know for doing that and
there's different ways to get at it
so getting at these facets there's a
there's a higher-order component called
with facets that you can use to to
actually get it you know get different
facets there is also facets that's
provided and some of those lifecycle
hooks so in the app did start app will
start there's also an expand with facets
feature so sometimes you need this stuff
at like load time and it's not available
yet it because it's it's a dependency at
you'll be of a circular and dependency
so he actually allows you to provide to
wrap it your your function with a expand
with facets and then it'll pass you in
the facets at the right time then you
can do whatever you want with that and
then pass back the result and so that
that allows you to get around the you
know dependency dependency problems and
then finally launch app will also return
a facets object and so you can use that
in certain circumstances as well just to
you know to get at the facets so lots of
different ways to get get that he's got
great documentation for this alright so
the code walkthrough so I got a couple
different things some samples and stuff
kind of show you how this works all
right so let me go over to the where's
my mouse
I see it over there okay there we go I
can see it over there everybody all
right so here's an example of the the
source index so it basically just called
launch app you provided the an array of
aspects you provide an array of features
and then you call register root app so
kind of what we talked about in this
case it's for a web app so we'll call
I'll call react Dom render it's actually
going to give me the root element and I
just use that and put it where I want on
the Dom I can also call register
serviceworker and whatever else you want
so that's kind of the same stuff that
comes right out of create react app so
that's you know that's that get you up
and going right there no you know not a
lot of work there okay don't want to be
modifying stuff I'm just trying to show
it all right all right so then the next
thing the features I've got a bunch of
different features here so I basically
built this thing up one feature at a
time just to kind of see how that would
work and you know and Kevin just got
this version one done just a few weeks
ago I've been working he's been working
really hard on on getting it out so we
could show it to you guys so I you know
I really wanted to bring it here to J's
comp because this is a place where new
things are shown and new ideas so I
think it's just really exciting I you
know library in concept so this is so
he's different different features I've
got here and so right now they're all
commented out like you could also have
enabled you know turn them on and off
with an able all right so let me let me
just go here and turn an app feature on
and let me jump down and do then do the
next one
and when do one more job just don't do
three at a time here and jump in alright
so we'll save that go over here to my
app all right
okay so it's a basic simple app it's got
a right now it's got a home screen and
about paged about page says there's some
content here the home screen just is
actually just showing me the features
that are turned on so even even really
gotten to the meet yet but that was just
kind of you know let's let's start with
something so what does this code look
like so the app first thing you look at
I've created a feature name I needed any
wanted to be camelcase so I just put a
camel case around it you know obviously
this is a single single word it's not a
problem but if you people copy paste
code so I want to make sure that if they
use a dash or something at its camelcase
so it would always work and then
basically here's my app component I've
got a browser router so I've got a react
router implementation here I've got a
header so it says bookmark notes and
then I'm passing in some some links and
some routes and so and again this was
gonna be this will be provided down
below here so I'm just rendering those
in a header and then down here in the
main and then here's my create feature
further for app and so here I'm saying
okay i'm i'm wanting star dot link comp
so i you know you come up with some kind
of naming convention of how you want to
map these things you know maybe there's
you know you could even put main menu or
something dot link that component so I'm
gonna say I need links and I need routes
and I'm gonna display all those and then
here I'm taking advantage of the wheel
start I'm going ahead and I'm gonna get
the facets object and the current route
element and I'm actually the one that's
creating this app so I know that there's
no there shouldn't be an existing brude
app and so then I go ahead and do a
fastest get and get whatever I want in
this case I'm getting the the link
components and I'm also saying this with
keys and that just says I want to go
ahead and get the name along with the
the component so since it's got a unique
name already I want both things and give
it to me back an array that's optional
you could just use index or whatever but
I go ahead and get the link so they get
the routes and then I pass them in and
render it so that that's basically gets
you up and going and that's what
rendered that that bookmark page and
then then the next thing let's look at
the about because that's you know real
simple
dear okay alright so again same similar
thing it's called about I'm saying that
the URL path is slash about you know you
could change that if you wanted but I
just used the that as a neat unique name
so here I'm creating a link component so
with link compassing in the the URL and
here's the route component passing in
the URL here's my you know great content
and then down here I'm saying alright
I'm defining this and expected to be
used somewhere it should be you should
match so I'm saying this feature name
about link dot component you could
obviously just type it out but I don't
want to just make this kind of generic
and so there there that's all you need
to be able to push that into the to the
system once it got pulled in by the
feature index launch app is able to just
find it and hook it up and match the
wildcards and then it shows up so then
the same thing and if we look at the the
other the home page one it's basically
just pulling in the features list and
then iterating through those and
printing those out so I'm basically just
want to show you know what features are
being defined it and and so it's same
kind of thing it's providing a link and
a component and alright and so then we
could go back over to features on see
there alright so now let's get a couple
more features going all right so I'm
gonna this now I'm gonna pull in the
list feature and a load canned feature
so let's say you're developing you don't
even have a you know you're not have the
data yet so you're gonna go ahead and
develop the list component and you know
next and then you know and then I'm
gonna go ahead and load it in some data
just some canned data so this is nice
because if you know maybe the API is not
even written yet you know so you could
just pull in an object structure that
you're used to
okay so it's one of the warnings so now
I'm actually since I'm starting to use
reducers and and and logic now I'm gonna
I've got to turn those on so I didn't
have those originally on because I
didn't need them so let me just flip
that on so back up here I've got the
feature Redux has an aspect and create
logic aspect from rejects logic so
let me turn those on and then and it'll
be ready to go all right let's see if
that solves it okay so now we've got a a
we can see all the different features
that are turned on here and then there's
our about and here's our list and the
list actually had a search you know so
we can search by whatever it's doing a
case insensitive search on this and you
know we can we can do remove and you
know and then of course it's the using
can data so if we refresh it then it
comes right back so it doesn't really
you know save anything but at least we
can make sure everything works and all
that so let's quickly look at that so
that what did that look like so the list
okay so for the list we had we've got a
we're using we're providing actions in
case somebody else wants to use some of
our actions we're creating we're
providing some selectors and then down
here I'm providing a link and a
component I'm saying for sure define and
use I'm expecting that to be used
somewhere these other ones may or may
not be used I'm just saying in future
somebody might need them and then up
here I'm you know as my Redux stuff so
I've got I'm creating some actions
there's some selectors some initial
state I've got I'm using a my feature
name as kind of the namespace for my
state
Sophy feature you has a nice way to be
able to merge your your reducers
together you just need to know where you
want it to to map it into the global
state so I'm just defining that as the
the path it could be you know something
dot something or whatever and then down
here we've got the create actions so
these are just using the Redux actions
to create some actions and they're here
I'm creating a reducer and then here's a
link again to the path and then here's
my selecting so I can do the the search
and then here I'm rendering that rending
or all my items and then exporting it
out as the great feature so that's
that's that and here's my go over to the
load canned here I've got my I can list
of data I'm using this expand with
facets so that I'm providing logic but
it's going to make a call back and say
give me facet so I can go ahead and pull
out the list out actions because that's
going to be giving me the type that I
want to match up here for greed X logic
so I'm creating this I'm doing a
asynchronous call and I'm just
responding with a canned list and then
that gets dispatched out and in rendered
so that and then here I'm using apt-get
start so I'm actually kicking that off
so it'll dispatch this this load when it
when it launches up so I don't you don't
have to have any hard-coded stuff there
all right
and then so then I think we're about
we're about wrapping up here but let me
get to the next the final one so this
mouse is hard so I think it features
there we go alright so now now let's say
let's go ahead and just finish it we
will go ahead and we're going to bring
in the air there's an add feature what
we're gonna add things and then we'll go
ahead and save things in local forage
it'll use whatever you know the browser
has for storage capabilities and so now
if we go back over here we've got all
the things turned on and then we can you
know add a new new thing here and it
shows up down here you know we still got
the search and about and lists and all
that so basically all working and yeah
so that that you know it basically works
I mean you can basically build these
things up you know feature at a time
make and basically swap the the new
storage feature in and swapped out the
old can feature and you know if
everything is all matched up then it'll
just boom you're ready to go so you know
it's pretty nice to build those just to
upgrade things you can easily roll back
to the previous thing you could do it
you know a/b testing and whatever so
that's kind of nice so let me go back to
the code and lock her hit the home
stretch here alright so
okay and then there's another app that
the Kevin wrote that's called eatery nod
and I'll just show you I won't go into
details with it no that's the only one
because the run late on time but
basically it's a you got links to it in
my and mine show notes he's got it it's
well documented with Doc diagrams
everything so this is like a it'll react
native app that you Expo app that you
can have restaurants be pulled in and
then create a list of those and then
basically it would be a random list so
if you have trouble deciding where to
take your your significant other you can
just pull up this app and press the
button it'll randomly pick something and
then you you can use that to to go and
so that's what he created it just kind
of wants something fun and so it's all
well document as far as that goes but he
does the same concept and since it has
all those hooks it works great for react
native and works great for for react web
so he's got authorization so it's it's
it's all it's a full app and he's got it
all blown out in two different separate
files and everything so I'll just let
you look at that on your own he is uh
let's see next all right okay so finally
the where was they out on here best
practices of just a few things to note I
think it's pretty simple to use once you
try it but you know the good thing is to
avoid cross feature imports so instead
of importing from feature a to feature B
directly use the you know use the facets
sharing and that makes it plug-and-play
so then if something else comes along
and implements those features you can
turn this one off turn that one up you
know so you don't have to be changing
you know a lot of files with imports and
things so that that's great it also
helps for swapping and for a/b testing
for mocking all that kind of stuff take
advantage of the uses contracts you know
the define used and they use so that
basically will catch spelling mistakes
use wildcards to be able to pull things
in for like the menus and all that
feature name is required to be unique
and it'll complain if it's not and and
so normally if you're using a single
file and you can put it right in there
but if you're using lots of other files
and you're going to use
in those files then it's a good practice
to put it in a separate file and just
import that into the various things
that'll prevent circular dependencies
and all that so that's just a kind of a
note that once you've been do any stuff
so so I think it really simplifies
things I mean it was I was really
impressed at how it got things up and
going and in it also just made it very
easy to get redux up and going and Redux
logic you didn't really have to mess
with you know we just pulled in the
aspect and then it did all the wiring
and then basically now we just create
features and define a reducer define a
logic and and it pulls it in wires add
up where it needs to go so I thought
that was really nice you know it's it's
kind of it's easier to do that than most
anything so besides to be able to do
feature development it's also nice for
just getting wired up flexible in
extensible this is he's you know is he
started with a few different
technologies but you could extend this
to anything it's really there's nothing
that's locking it down he's kind of got
some great documentation here to to show
that it could be used on other languages
and frameworks the let me just bring up
the page here so this is feed chaos
Kevin a est feature U is his website
again he's got a lot of great Doc's in
here he's got a feature UJS that org is
his documentation site and it's it's
awesome you know you just goes through
and explains everything how it works
down here is the core API you know so it
breaks out all the things I talked about
and in difference one thing I didn't
mention is it kind of uses objects for a
lot of the parameters and so sometimes
the way this API there where this
renders it doesn't really show you those
are it's like a named parameter or a D
structured Brammer and so but there is
basically objects that you're passing
into for a lot of these parameters and
so you don't have to necessarily use all
of them if you just need one or two you
can just specify the ones you need so
just just a note of there but yeah this
is a great he does great Jackman tation
so this is fantastic for that let's see
I think we're down to the final thing so
that slides were at code winds calm /j s
comp 2018 there's the other repo stuff
contact me if you've got questions or
whatever I'm happy to answer that or
have a beer later you know let me know
you got ideas or or things you want to
use it for
Twitter handle and github is Jeff Biscay
and I appreciate let me speak to you
thank you
[Applause]